ALL THE LOCKDOWN RULES THEY WANT
YOU TO OBEY, BUT FIRST, THE
GREAT AMERICAN SELLOUT.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT
ANGLE.
>> DURING THE LONG COVID
INTERRUPTED CAMPAIGN OF 2020,
AMERICANS HEARD A LOT ABOUT THIS
GUY, JOE FROM SCRANTON.
>> HE SEES THE WORLD FROM PARK
AVENUE.
I SEE IT FROM SCRANTON, WHO IS
LOOKING OUT FOR THE AVERAGE
PERSON OUT THERE?
PEOPLE I GREW UP WITH INSTANT
SCRANTON, THAT’S LESSON I’VE
NEVER FORGOTTEN.
I GREW UP SURROUNDED BY A LOT OF
HARD-WORKING FOLKS IN SCRANTON,
PENNSYLVANIA.
>> SADLY, MILLIONS OF VOTERS
TOOK A MATCH IS WORD.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT
HIS NEARLY FIVE DECADES PUSHING
ALL THESE POLICIES THAT ARE VERY
PLEASING TO BIG BUSINESS AND HIS
BIPARTISAN ESTABLISHMENT FIGURES
.
THESE OUR POLICIES THAT ENDED UP
ROBBING HARD-WORKING AMERICANS
OF THEIR WEALTH AND THEIR
OPPORTUNITY.
BIDENS FAMILY MEANWHILE RAKED IN
THE DOUGH TREATING ON HIS NAME
AND HIS POLITICAL POSITION AT
HOME AND ABROAD PRAY TO THEY
DIDN’T CARE ABOUT REPORTING ANY
OF THIS BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS
CORRUPT.
TO BLOW THE LID ON JOE WOULD
MEAN BLOWING THE LID ON
THEMSELVES FOR THEIR COMPLICIT
SILENCE THROUGH ALL THESE YEARS
DESPITE WHAT THEY CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT THE LITTLE PEOPLE DO IN
THE MEDIA.
THE WORST THING ABOUT ALL OF
THIS IS THAT FOR HIS ENTIRE
CAREER, ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PAST FEW YEARS.
HE PUT ON THE BIG SHOW, CLAIMING
TO BE THE GUY WHO CARED SO MUCH
ABOUT THE LITTLE MIDDLE-CLASS.
>> WE KNOW GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS
GIVEN OUT ON MY WATCH THAT DON’T
MAKE ALL THEIR PRODUCTS HERE IN
AMERICA.
MILLIONS OF NEW HIGH PAYING
UNION JOBS, THE POWER TO CHANGE
THIS COUNTRY IS IN YOUR HANDS.
IN YOUR HANDS.
YOUR HANDS.
>> OF COURSE, THE REJOINDER TO
ALL OF THAT WAS AND IS, SO WHY
DOESN’T HE DO ANY OF THIS IN THE
LAST 47 YEARS, OR AT LEAST SAY
THAT EIGHT YEARS YOU WERE VICE
PRESIDENT.
COME ON, SHOULD HE ASSUMED THE
PRESIDENCY, DON’T EXPECT THE
PRESS TO DO HIS JOB AT HOLDING
HIM TO HIS WORD ON ANY OF THESE
MADE IN AMERICA PROMISES.
THEY KNOW THEIR LIVES FOR THEY
KNOW THEY’RE ALL WISE THEY ARE
DESIGNED TO PLACATE THE WORKING
CLASS AND OLDER AMERICANS WHO A
FEW YEARS EARLIER HAD VOTED FOR
TRUMP.
THE FACT RIGHT NOW IS HE PLANS
TO REVERSE NEARLY ALL OF THE
PRESIDENTS HARD-WON SUCCESSES
FOR WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS
VARIED MOST IMPORTANTLY, DRUM
SUCCESS ON TRADE AND IMMIGRATION
.
TODAY WE CREATE IS JUST PART’S
TRANSITION TEAM WITH RADICAL
OPEN BOULDERS FANATICS.
FOR INSTANCE, THE HEAD OF THE
AGENCY REVIEW GROUP IS THE
FORMER CHIEF COUNSEL AT THE U.S.
TO VISIT AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES UNDER OBAMA PERIGEE
CURRENTLY HAS AN ACTIVIST GROUP
THAT CALLS FOR PUTTING
11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
AMERICANS ON A PATH TO FULL
CITIZENSHIP.
A SWEEPING CHANGE TO AMERICA
WOULD JUST REQUIRE ACTUAL
LEGISLATION, SO THEY COULD BE
COMPROMISED AND WORK BETWEEN THE
PARTIES, A KEY GUY AND ADDIE
JUST DON’T SEE IT THAT WAY.
>> EXTEND THE OLIVE BRANCH, LET
THEM KNOW WHAT YOUR PROGRAMS ARE
, ASK THEM TO JOIN, AND IF
THEY DON’T, THAT’S DO IT WITH
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER.
I USED TO SAY THAT TO BARACK
OBAMA ALL THE TIME, AND I’M
SAYING IT TO YOU.
>> EXECUTIVE ORDERS, THAT’S WHAT
HE’S TALKING ABOUT.
A BLANKET AMNESTY WOULD IN AND
OF ITSELF BECOME A MAGNET FOR
MILLIONS OF ADDITIONAL ILLEGALS.
>> A GUARANTEE THAT WAGES WERE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
AND ENTRY-LEVEL AMERICAN WORKERS
.
THAT’S HOW IT ALWAYS PLAYS OUT
VARIED BUT BIDENS PLAN FOR MASS
WAGE GOES EVEN FURTHER THAN THAT
.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, CBS NEWS GOT
A HOLD OF THE IMMIGRATION PLAN.
ASIDE FROM MASS AMNESTY, BAD
ENOUGH, HERE IS THE BIG GOAL.
HE’S GOING TO HALT DEPORTATIONS
FOR 100 DAYS UPON TAKING OFFICE.
AND FIGURE OUT THEN I GUESS HOW
TO AVOID DEPARTING AS MANY
ILLEGALS AS POSSIBLE BY
NARROWING THE SCOPE OF ANY
ENFORCEMENT IN THE FUTURE.
BIDEN WILL ALSO END THE
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
HE’S ALSO GOING TO RIP UP
AGREEMENTS FROM GUATEMALA, EL
SALVADOR, AND HONDURAS TO TAKE
IN THOSE REJECTED ASYLUM
SPEAKERS.
BIDEN WILL RAISE THE CAP ON
REFUGEES AS WELL.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE TAKE IN ABOUT
15,000 A YEAR FROM ALL ACROSS
THE GLOBE.
HE IS GOING TO RAISE IT TO
125,000 ANNUALLY.
HE’S ALSO GOING TO ELIMINATE THE
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ON PEOPLE
COMING FROM TERRORIST HOTBEDS
THAT TRUMPET INTO PLACE YEARS
AGO.
EVERY ONE OF THESE ACTIONS WILL
LEAD TO EITHER A MORE DANGEROUS
AMERICA, OR LOWER WAGES FOR
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS
INCLUDING AS I SAID IMMIGRANTS
AND MINORITIES WHO OBEY THE LAWS
, JUST WANT TO EARN A DECENT
WAGE FOR A HARD DAYS WORK VARIED
BIDENS WEALTHY BACKERS, THEY
BELIEVE THAT HONEST AMERICANS
MUST ALWAYS SACRIFICE AND NEVER
COMPLAIN, DON’T YOU DARE
COMPLAIN ABOUT WELCOMING IN MORE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS INTO THE
COUNTRY.
BIG TECH WAS LIVID WHEN DONALD
TRUMP PUT A FREEZE ON WHAT WE’RE
CALLED EIGHT BACK IN JUNE.
WHAT TRUMP WANTED TO DO WAS
PROTECT AMERICAN TECH JOBS
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING A FLOOD OF
FOREIGN TECH WORKERS INTO THE
COUNTRY.
BUT BIDEN, HE DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
PROTECTING AMERICAN TECH WORKERS
JOBS.
>> STREAMING LINING THE
NATURALIZATION PROCESS.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR GREEN CARD
HOLDERS TO MOVE THROUGH THE
BACKLOG.
BY THE WAY, HE ENDED H ONE B
VISAS THE REST OF THIS YEAR.
THAT WILL NOT BE IN MY
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO COME
AND HAVE BUILT THIS COUNTRY.
>> SO MASSIVE UNEMPLOYMENT UNDER
JOE’S FUTURE LOCKDOWN, AND MORE
PEOPLE COMING IN WITH FEWER JOBS
.
THAT’S GREAT.
OF COURSE WITH JOE, THINGS
ALWAYS GET WORSE.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLANS WOULD DIVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
>> I LOVE THE HAND RAISES.
FREE HEALTHCARE FOR PEOPLE WHO
BREAK THE LAW.
IT WILL BE RAISED TO PAY FOR IT
ALL.
BIDEN’S GREAT AMERICAN SELLOUTS
IS JUST AS BAD BY THE WAY IN THE
FOREIGN POLICY REALM.
HE HAS A NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM
THAT IS BASICALLY UNINTERESTED
IN THE WHOLE PART OF ITS DUTIES.
A FORMER TRUMP PENTAGON OFFICIAL
SAYS BIDEN IS AIMING FOR BILLS
AND EFFECTIVE BIPARTISAN DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT LEADERSHIP TEAM.
REACHING OUT TO MORE FORMANT
FORMAL OFFICIALS WHO WE’RE
APPOINTED BY JIM MADDOX TO TALK
ABOUT THE TRANSITION AND
POTENTIALLY SERVICE.
LET ME TRANSLATE THAT EXPLAIN IN
PLAIN ENGLISH.
BASICALLY THEY ARE GOING TO
RETAKE CONTROL OF OUR FOREIGN
POLICY AND LESS TRUMP ACTUALLY
PULLS ALL OF OUR TROOPS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN BY THE END OF THE
YEAR, TROOPS WILL BE STUCK THERE
FOR FOUR MORE YEARS.
TRUMP REFUSAL TO GO ALONG WITH
THE MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
IS WHY THE HOOP LOVE HIM, BUT
THE TOP MILITARY BRASS AND THE
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS, NOT SO MUCH
.
CASE IN POINT, THE OUTGOING
SPECIAL ENVOY TO SYRIA JUST
TODAY BOASTED THAT HE AND OTHER
MILITARY LEADERS FLAGRANTLY LIED
TO THE PRESIDENT AND MISLED THE
PUBLIC TO KEEP FOOD ROUTES ON
THE GROUND IN SYRIA AFTER TRUMP
SAID THEY ARE COMING HOME.
NOW, IT’S OUTRAGEOUS AND
DISGUSTING THAT CAREER OFFICIALS
WOULD PUT AMERICAN SOLDIERS IN
HARM’S WAY FOR THEIR OWN
PERSONAL GOALS AND POLITICAL
VIEWS.
BY THE WAY, THESE ARE GOALS THAT
THE VOTERS REJECTED WHEN THEY
ELECTED TRUMP IN 2016.
THEY WANTED OUT OF THESE WARS
BREAK NOT SURPRISINGLY, THE
MEDIA CELEBRATED THIS FLAGRANT
DERELICTION OF DUTY, ABUSE,
DISOBEDIENCE, WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO CALL IT.
YET PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS STILL
FIGHTING FOR AMERICANS.
TODAY HE ANGERED THE CAMPAIGN
FOR EMPLOYERS WITH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER BANNING U.S. INVESTMENTS
IN COMPANIES CONTROLLED BY THE
CHINESE MILITARY.
THE VOTE TALLY DOESN’T MEAN THAT
AMERICA ENDORSES BIDEN OPEN
BORDERS, PRO- WAR IDIOCY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
THE GOP CLEANED UP IN STATE
LEGISLATURES, THEY FLIPPED AT
LEAST TEN HOUSE SEATS.
AND IF HE WINS, THIS UPCOMING
RUNOFF BOTH RUNOFFS IN GEORGIA,
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A STRONG
AGAINST THE LEFT EXTREME AGENDA.
AND TOMORROW, WE’RE GOING TO SEE
THAT AMERICA FIRST ENERGY ON
FULL DISPLAY WHEN TRUMP
SUPPORTERS FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THIS
CONTESTED ELECTION.
REMEMBER FOUR YEARS AGO, THE
MEDIA HEALED THE WOMEN’S MARCH
IS A REPUDIATION OF TRUMP
SELECTION.
SO WILL THE MEDIA PROVIDE THE
SAME TYPE OF NARRATIVE THIS
WEEKEND?
THE RESISTANCE HASN’T IN NEW
FAITH, AND THIS TIME THEY ARE
RESISTING JOE BIDEN.
HIS HANDLERS, HIS DONORS, AND
ALL OF THEIR EFFORTS TO SELL OUT